when it comes to repairs give your car
the vip treatment vip auto center the
sponsors of this next segment have
opened up a fourth location check it out
well we're having a grand opening today
here at our vip automotive commercial
center
[Music]
[Music]
well what makes this property a little
unique we do mostly commercial diesel
trucks out of here but we do the gas
fleets heavy equipment rvs boats
cars whatever you got we do it down here
but we decided to bring to the west side
a diesel repair facility here we are
folks the size is about three acres here
we have five thousand square feet we're
gonna have six lifts here um we can
accommodate about 400 trucks here and
rvs and boats and it's all secured
um i know my competition tends to make
you wait about a month we get you in
same day let you know what's going on
with the vehicle and we try to have it
out within 72 hours the specials we have
going on on all four locations right now
is our castor oil all casserole oil
changes will be 50 off for the next
couple weeks
repairs for all minor repairs
maintenance 20
off for the next two weeks at all four
locations it's actually at 4701 north
rancho on the corner of lone mountain
and rancho business hours here are from
7 a.m to 6 p.m monday through saturday
we are close sundays here you can get us
on our website at
vipautoservicecenterlv.com
[Applause]
[Music]
if you see bob in that f-250 lifted
f-250 or the tow truck and you mentioned
where i'm at that day you get a free oil
change that day on bob so all they have
to do is call one of my local stores
four to choose from wherever you see me
call me and i'm gonna get you that free
oil change for the day
vip auto center has four locations 4701
north rancho that's the new one also
locations on west sahara north decatur
in west charleston call 702-846-5480
or visit vip auto service center lv.com
they have a special offer going on
twenty percent off all minor repairs
fifty percent off castro oil changes
okay